on me disait dans mon enfance les Grecs
ce sont les Européens les romances les
Romains ce sont les Américains ces
réducteurs
il y a dans cette comparaison deux idées
il y a l'idée que Rome et la fille de la
Grèce comme les américains sont les fils
de la vieille Europe et puis il y a
l'idée que
les Grecs ont été essentiellement des
créateurs ils ont été du côté de ceux
qui fournissent la matrice
intellectuelle et les Romains n'auraient
été que d'habils organisateurs
finalement
et c'est un peu l'opposition
traditionnelle entre la pensée
spéculative et la pensée pratique et en
fait je pense que c'est insuffisant
parce que déjà les Grecs n'ont pas
toujours été les créateurs au-delà du 5e
siècle le Grand Siècle de la Grèce dans
les derniers siècles quatrième troisième
siècle il y a plus vraiment de
production de savoir il se renferme dans
les rudition
et à l'inverse si les Romains ont copié
la Grèce ce sont les grands copieurs de
la Grèce toute la statuaire antique et
nous est connue par les romains qui ont
copié les Grecs ils ne se sont pas
bornés à copier ils ont copié aussi en
innovant ils ont eu leur propre
architecture ils ont inventé par exemple
la queue qu'ils ont inventé un monument
comme le Panthéon qui est à Rome et qui
est absolument unique au monde ils ont
une pensée originale et donc finalement
ils ont assuré la passation de cet
aritage grec mais ils ont un suffit
aussi leur génie propre
est-ce que ça donne une idée
en tout cas
pardon l'historien journaliste
Jean-Marie poppert dans un livre de
référence qui intitulé les mères patries
écrit en substance Athènes à apporter le
sens de l'individu Rome le sens de
l'État est-ce que c'est vrai ou est-ce
que c'est réducteur c'est à la fois vrai
réducteur parce que oui bien sûr
l'individu est très présent dans la
pensée grecque dans la pensée de Platon
en particulier mais en Grèce il faut pas
il faut pas faire de l'individu tel que
le conçoit la Grèce antique le parangon
de l'individu moderne de l'indivialisme
actuel parce que l'individu en Grèce
antique dans la Grèce antique est
toujours à comprendre comme faisant
partie d'un corps d'un corps social
d'une serre politique d'une sphère
religieuse et l'ensemble de ces
différentes sphères leur réunion c'est
la cité moi il en quoi c'est vrai que
les Grecs n'ont pas au plan politique
dépassés le stade de la cité alors que
les Romains ont dépassé la cité ils ont
ils ont fondé un empire donc on peut
parler effectivement de sens de l'État
chez les Romains mais de la même façon
attention c'est pas l'état au sens de
l'État moderne tel qu'il va se
développer à partir du 16e siècle en
Europe c'est à dire que l'État à Rome
c'est un état très très basique d'une
certaine façon à une organisation
minimum en revanche c'est le modèle
impérial inventé par Rome qu'il a est
une nouveauté absolue et si on devait
résumer finalement on pourrait dire que
les Grecs ont diffusé leur propre
culture en adoptant les mœurs des autres
par exemple Alexandre le Grand qui qui
s'habille à la Perse alors que les
Romains ont diffusé la culture des
autres des peuples qu'ils ont conquis en
y faisant passer leur propre meurt par
exemple la virtuelle les vertus romaines
la fidélité le courage la probité le
labeur tout ça ce sont les mœurs
proprement romaine
l'Occident n'a pas le monopole de
l'héritage gréco-romain non alors des
traces de l'héritage antique on en
trouve au Pakistan on en trouve dans la
Perse sassanie dont on en trouve dans le
monde oméiade et dans le monde musulman
en général la différence c'est que c'est
Rémy braque qui le dit dans ce numéro de
Figari histoire la passation s'est faite
pour ainsi dire d'un seul coup c'est à
dire que ils se sont ils se sont
appropriés une fois pour une fois le
l'héritage antique là où le monde
occidental il est revenu en permanence
l'héritage antique pour le monde
occidental c'est quelque chose qui était
retravaillé retravaillé retravaillé et
au fil des siècles l'Europe c'est choisi
d'une certaine façon c'est rechoisi
l'Antiquité en permanence comme son
aïeul son aïeul préféré vous voyez en
plus tous les textes grecs n'ont pas été
étudiés par les autres civilisations
c'est en particulier le savoir grec qui
a été
étudié par eux mais la littérature par
exemple leur a leur a totalement échappé
dans ce que nous devons une antiquité
gréco-romaine il y a à vous lire le
catholicisme mais est-ce que là c'est
pas de pardon de l'appropriation
culturelle ça fait rire d'ailleurs
certains internautes qui font du mauvais
esprit à ce niveau-là
parce que le christianisme toujours je
vous le rappeler mon cher Geoffroy est
né en Palestine oui alors le
christianisme évidemment est né dans un
monde juif au plan de la pensée de la
religion des mœurs évidemment mais il
est né au plan temporel dans une Judée
qui a été romanisée il est né dans la
province romaine de Judée qui va devenir
la Palestine officiellement soit Adrien
au deuxième siècle et surtout le
développement du christianisme s'est
fait dans l'Empire romain je dirais même
que le développement de la faveur de
l'Empire romain à la faveur de l'Empire
romain c'est le c'est le l'Empire romain
qui a donné au christianisme les moyens
de son expansion ne serait-ce que par
son réseau routier les routes de
l'Empire les ports maritimes de l'Empire
tout ça c'est Rome et
l'une des raisons pour lesquelles par
exemple l'apôtre Paul peut faire autant
de voyages c'est sympa effectivement
Saint-Paul il est cit bien romain et il
se déplace dans tout l'Empire à travers
tout le bassin méditerranéen en
utilisant les moyens que lui offre
l'Empire et il meurt il meurt à Rome
donc toute cette diffusion du
christianisme s'est faite
en lien absolu avec le monde romain mais
le christianisme a été lui-même en but
au monde romain puisque vous savez que
les persécutions ont débuté très vite
parce que les chrétiens refusaient de
rendre le culte impérial et une dernière
chose qui à mon avis très intéressante
c'est que la première grande hérésie de
l'Église c'est l'arianisme donc on se
doute c'est un peu plus tard ce
quatrième siècle on est toujours sous
l'Empire romain et on bute sur la
question de la divinité de Jésus est-ce
qu'il est vraiment le Fils de Dieu ou
pas est-ce qu'il est de même substance
que le père et les régions qui ont été
le plus latinisées sont celles qui
demeurent catholiques et la région les
moins latinisée le monde germatique en
particulier devient à rien et ces gens
Robert Pitt qui qui l'observent
hérétique de l'arianisme et Jean Rob
observe de façon très judicieuse que
c'est la même carte géographique que la
Réforme protestante la Réforme
protestante a été un problème
adopté par les pays les moins latinisés
qui a un problème avec l'incarnation de
la divinité enfin tous les cas qui
conteste un certain nombre de points qui
sont liés à l'incarnation et à la
divinité du Christ et à la maternité
enfin maternité divine de Marie si on
fait l'inventaire vous dites il y a une
partie des langues parlées en Europe et
en Occident qu'ils sont doivent tout à
l'héritage gréco-romain ce sont les
langues ce sont les sept à huit langues
romanes notamment oui et parmi celle-là
le français au premier chef puisque 85%
des Italiens sont meilleurs en latin
mais
85% de notre patrimoine
de lexical provient du latin en
ligne directe si vous voulez y aller
langromanes entre les deux au septième
huitième siècle mais le résultat c'est
que le lexique vient du monde romain et
notre syntaxe c'était même encore très
calqué sur la langue la langue romaine
si les Romains n'avaient pas parlé latin
nous ne parlerions pas français
aujourd'hui le droit également qui a été
conçu à ce moment à ce moment-là oui
alors le droit c'est le cœur du du
réacteur romain on pourrait dire grec
aussi alors c'est surtout les Romains
qui ont codifié les Romains qui ont été
des passionnés du code ils ont repris
les étages rhétoriques effectivement au
juridique des des Grecs mais c'est eux
qui ont codifié le droit qui ont édicté
les maximes qu'on connaît et le droit
romain dans tous les traités qui ont été
produits à largement disparu si ce n'est
dans les compilations qui ont été faites
par les empereurs Théodose
Justinien donc cinquième sixième siècle
et et et par ces deux codes qui ont été
qui nous ont été légués il a continué
d’infuser dans le monde occidental
jusqu'à aujourd'hui l'architecture
également l'architecture c'est peut-être
la partie la plus spectaculaire parce
que le modèle des temples grecs est
passé à Rome et le modèle des temples
romains inspiré des Grecs avec leurs
trois ordres doriques ni Corinthiens
issus du monde grec c'est ce qu'on voit
dans la moindre sous-préfecture
française pour ne prendre que l'exemple
de la France mais on pourrait on
pourrait prendre des exemples dans
d'autres pays latins je pense à la
Roumanie en particulier
tout ce qu'on voit même un pari l'Arc de
Triomphe évidemment c'est un modèle
romain l'Arc de Triomphe et l'Arche de
la Défense qui a été bâti plus loin
derrière dans la perspective c'est une
imitation aussi d'un arc de triomphe
romain finalement de l'arc de l'étoile
mais
ça infuse en fait l'occidental ça c'est
un point qui est passionnant dans dans
le numéro du dernier numéro du Figaro
histoire c'est que c'est une thèse qui
défendue tout au numéro c'est c'est ce
qui leur rend passionnant c'est que vous
expliquez la redécouverte de la culture
antique à suscité des renaissances
stimulantes et flamboyantes on passe
notre temps on passe l'histoire à
redécouvrir et
[Musique]
continental on continue à traduire à
retraduire les auteurs antiques on
continue à réfléchir sur les textes on
continue à établir des systèmes
critiques ça c'est quelque chose qui est
typique du monde occidental dans sa
position d'héritier actifs
il y a aussi et ça qui est intéressant
ça continue après la Renaissance
italienne vous il y a bien sûr Napoléon
qui est empereur et qui s'inspire de la
romantique au 20e siècle on a également
Mussolini qui veut ressusciter la
grandeur de Rome et la grandeur
impériale et impérialiste de Rome et il
y a le point commun de tout ça c'est
quand même les révolutions qui
elles-mêmes puisent dans le dans le
répertoire antique mais même la
Troisième République oui parce que
l'évolution le culte de héros et des
héros et que Roman particulier
un réservoir quasiment inépuisable de
héros alors surtout le héros de l'époque
républicaine évidemment qui intéresse
les révolutionnaires et pour ne prendre
que l'exemple de la Révolution française
le terrain était préparé par Montesquieu
et Rousseau qui regarde beaucoup du côté
des héros antiques par la redécouverte
de plus tard qui écrit les Vies
parallèles ou qui ont été traduits par
Jacques camion au 16e siècle on peut
rappeler ce que ce que sont les Vies
parallèles plus tard mais en parallèle
les récits de biographie l'une d'un Grec
l'autre d'un roman et il compare leur
ouverture respective alors là pour les
héros révolutionnaires comme Camille
Desmoulins qui dit au collège le collège
de l'Ancien Régime dans les années
1760-70 nous avons été gorgés d'Athènes
et de Rome et ces modèles évidemment les
révolutionnaires n'en ont qu'une
connaissance très superficielle
ils prennent ce qu'ils intéressent par
exemple ils sont ils sont obnubilés par
la loi ils sont venus par la vertu donc
on va chercher les héros les plus
vertueux comme Cincinnatus Cincinnatus
c'est un héros qui met fin qui instaure
là qui instaure la République romaine
qui met fin à la royauté il est probe et
en plus quand il a terminé se battre
contre les ennemis il retourne comme
paysan derrière la charrue alors ça
c'est l'idéal révolutionnaire par
excellence est-ce que Rome est
Athènes inspire encore aujourd'hui
oui il y a une inspiration continue je
vous disais ne serait-ce que qu'à
travers ça qu'on retraduise au maire et
qu'on retraduise plus tard mais prenez
l'exemple de la statuaire tant qu'on
fait de la stature anthropomorphique on
est redevable pour ne prendre que les
gens
humains plus ou moins stylisé et qu'elle
soit elle reste tributaire de Rome de la
Grèce la Grèce elle-même épuisée dans
les modèles égyptiens particuliers mais
le sens des proportions la noblesse si
vous voulez de ce qui fait une statue
idéale ça nous vient de la mais
justement aujourd'hui quand même surtout
depuis l'avènement du surréalisme au
début du 20e siècle on ne puise moins
dans ce enfin en tous les cas on
s'inspire moins de cet art est-ce qu'il
y a pas une rupture avec cet
héritage Gréco romain aujourd'hui
on rappellera je sais plus qui disait la
définition du topis c'est tout ce qui
n'a pas existé dans l'Empire romain et
est-ce qu'on n'est pas justement
aujourd'hui dans l'âge des utopies dans
l'âge de l'individualisme forcené et
donc dans l'âge de la rupture par
rapport à cet héritage oui ça renvoie ce
que je vous disais sur l'individu c'est
à dire que si on prend pour modèle de
l'indivision ambiant le modèle de
l'individu selon la Grèce on fait fausse
route l'individualisme ambiant justement
il ne se reconnaît pas héritier donc de
ce point de vue là évidemment il y a la
tentation d'une utopie il y a la
tentation d'une rupture et il faut
résister puisque on réalise que tout ce
qu'on est au plan de la pensée on le
doit en très grande partie à cet
héritage Geoffroy question de Philippe
pourquoi les Romains n'ont pas étendu
leur empire vers l'Afrique alors ils
l'ont ils l'ont ils l'ont étendu quand
même en Afrique du Nord je pense
qu'après le temps leur a manqué pour
descendre vous avez fait d'ailleurs un
très bon reportage en Libye je me
souviens oui alors pour voir des ruines
oui alors la plus belle cité je pense
qu'on avait du monde romain c'est les
petits smile la ville natale de
l'empereur Septime Sévère c'est un
endroit absolument extraordinaire et les
Italiens ne s'y sont pas trompés ce
quand ils sont arrivés en Libye en 1911
ils ont remis debout tous les vestiges
de la cité antique et ils ont défié des
cartes postales on voyait un légionnaire
un squelette de légionnaires avec son
casque sur la plage de Libye de l'épice
Mania qui tend son glaive au résultats
de de soldat italien de 1912 en lui
disant voilà je je t'ai attendu jusque
là prend la relève
le port de Carthage il y a également un
certain également en Algérie où il y a
donné
des vestiges alors un internaute nous
demande alors Claude est-ce que Napoléon
a copié les Romains alors Napoléon a
absolument Copé les Romains il suffit de
regarder le style Empire allez visiter
l'Hôtel de Beauharnais à Paris qui le
plus bel hôtel particulier qu'on est en
style Empire aller au château de
Fontainebleau vous verrez que dans le SI
l'Empire tout est absolument romain il y
a aussi la couche égyptienne qui
provient en partie de l'expédition
d'Égypte et puis surtout il y a quelque
chose absolument étonnant c'est que
Napoléon a fait tout ça sans jamais être
allé à Rome de sa vie bon il y a plein
de choses encore à dire magnifique et
puis bien sûr tout le 17e et le 18e
siècle aussi s'inspire de l'héritage
romain merci beaucoup Geoffroy cahier
aux sources de la civilisation
occidentale c'est le passionnant et
dernier numéro
du Figaro hors série inutile du Figaro
je la refais c'est le dernier numéro du
Figaro Histoire bien sûr le Figaro
hors-série est aussi à lire mais le
Figaro Histoire est à lire en priorité
ces jours-ci et cette effectivement ça
vient tout juste de sortir merci
beaucoup aux sources de la civilisation
occidentale d'art donc ce que nous
devons à l'Antiquité gréco-romaine à
très vite merci beaucoup Geoffroy et
merci à vous de nous avoir suivi à très
vite sur le Figaro